[Music]
welcome back to the gin joint podcast
brought to you by post mates whether you
need back scratching tool pancakes black
pepper sushi
whatever you need Taco Bell post mates
is there to bring it to you wherever you
may be so download the post mates app
right now download that right now and
use coach energy lien and you get $100
towards free delivery credit for your
first seven days using the app so check
it out it is amazing I use it all the
time
Thank You PO space we are fun today yeah
yeah what do you want to do boy I was
thinking some gymnastics training mental
gymnastics training
Rita Long's thumb wars okay ready yeah
one two keep your thumbs really straight
nine ten eleven twelve what what is that
no it's supposed to be kiss bow then you
fight okay yes Wow
I moaning Oh moaning okay oh I give up
yes one one two three four five six
seven
fast forward ten minutes 37 38 what can
I say thank you guys for listening it's
been a good one we're back from
twitchcon which was a lot of fun it was
fun
we went to San Jose and played in the
broadcaster Royale pub G tournament at
twitchcon which was a blast and an
experience I never ever thought I would
get to have in my life also we got to
meet a whole bunch of our favorite
streamers and friends online in person
which makes and inks as the 32 year old
lady I can say confidently it's not a
direction
I thought the wind was gonna blow me in
but here we are well that was you
accounting for wind not tornadoes
getting wrecked on stage by pros ladies
men might non-binary friends I'm alright
we were at one point literally drinking
wine and playing pub G on the tournament
floor 32 year old lady just living her
buzz life it's pretty hype not gonna lie
it was drinking wine and playing pub G
in public was a little bit a little bit
top 10 life experiences yes a pretty
sick know someone was suggesting so
since we talk a lot about our astrology
signs and that kind of thing something
I'm I don't really know that well is
numerology what is numerology okay I
mean see I'm not are you just gonna
loudly slurp your Hydra flask er we
really had to do that I know you [ __ ]
okay alright let me click on a link that
says click you know what oh okay this is
called astrology - numerology calm it so
I reading this from so make sure you let
me know in the comments how much of a
novice I am and how much I don't know
what I'm saying cuz I'm reading it I
don't know dot-gov no that's not courage
government project okay
numerology introduction Julian what
hello what are you ready
why yeah okay there's a this says read
before digging in put down your shovel
okay wait so you put down your shovel
you just said you were getting ready to
attack no I did nothing about attacking
Ares this isn't a competition we're
reading about numerology that's sweet
okay numerology is perhaps the easiest
of the occult arts ooh okay so we into
the occult arts is what they say Nicole
what you said occult yes so this is a
cult no Oh see see you LT a space see
you LT
to understand and use all you need is
the birthday and the complete name of an
individual to unlock all of the secrets
numbers all okay even write down my name
Ronald okay stop
Livingston your name I was born on April
30 second stop 20:31
okay do you want to do this I am from
the future
I'll wait uh yeah no idea Ronald
Livingston wants to do it okay I'm sorry
I'm Julian all right I was doing a
little roleplay sorry I was testing it
out you know if you'd like it or not
like it when a doesn't like your
roleplay like it at all that was weird
we'll get there oh my god okay there are
11 numbers used in construction
constructing numerology charts these
numbers are 1 2 3 4 5 11 no 9 and 10
no there's no 10 or anything from 11 22
so it's 1 2 3 4 7 8 9 11 22 I hate it
I'm down larger numbers that occur from
adding the numbers in the complete
birthdate or from the values assigned to
each name are reduced by adding the
digits together until the sum achieved
is one of the core numbers merely add
the components of the larger number
together for peasley if necessary until
a single digit or the master numbers 11
or 22 results each of these number
represents different characteristics and
expressions master numbers are the only
two exceptions to the rule of reducing
to the single digit the master numbers
11 and 22 are reputedly intensified
versions of the single digit number they
replaced 2 & 4 these numbers suggest a
potential for a high degree of learning
and/or achievement very often in a more
stressful environment in most
individuals the master numbers operate
at a much more tangible or practical
level becoming essentially the same as
the digit single-digit parallel
the first consideration of numerology is
often the date of birth this date
expressed numerically as month month day
day year year year year is used to
determine what is called the Life Path
number which is what we're gonna figure
out in a variety of other factors in the
numerology reading we will be also be
converting your full birth name
asterisks I'm gonna read that note in a
second to a number letters and numbers
you will learn are always one in the
same here is a chart of the values
assigned to each of the letters okay so
like one is a 2 is B 3 is C D so the
chart goes we need a piece of paper no
no because I found a website where you
just type in your birthday okay but for
your name yeah
so if you want to get your phone out
your phone out do you see this chart
this this goes one through nine okay so
the first nine letters of the alphabet
are like a is 1 B is 2 C is 3 then it
goes to I is 9 then it starts over with
J is 1 K is 2 L is 3 M is 4 okay I'm
trying to write down the key I'll help
you with this chart wait what key no
it's right here I'll help you so I'm
writing down okay no you're not writing
anything down yet because first what
we're gonna do is our birth date uh-huh
[Music]
so I think in in layman's terms if you
just take your like my birthday is Oh
915 86 so you add all the numbers
together and then you keep adding them
until you get a single digit you know
what I mean okay so like if I pull up my
calculator I could have read that wrong
but if I add 0 plus 9 plus 1 plus 5 plus
8 plus 6 oh wait I forgotten one a 9
plus 1 plus 9 because 1986
that's 78 then 7 plus 8 15 then 1 plus 5
well yes what's 7 plus 8 what do you
mean what's 7 plus 8 you're just you're
adding all the digits together oh I
don't I don't really know okay so I need
a little help
but I do know that there's a website
that just calculates it for you okay
okay we'll link the wet we'll try to
link the website but you you yeah so I'm
gonna click on this it says Life Path
number and you basically enter okay
if you want I'll help you manually add
it for those of you at home if you don't
want to go to the whatever the Life Path
number is the sum of the birth date this
number represents who you are at birth
and the native traits that you carry
with you throughout life the the most
important number that will be discussed
here is your Life Path number so that's
where calculating the Life Path
describes the nature of this journey
through life a Life Path number is
established from the date of birth first
add the month the day and year together
to arrive at a total month day in here
okay so 4 plus 1 7 plus + 1 9 9 - mm-hmm
- equals 20 ok 13 hold on stay there ok
you add the month day and year together
drive attach old next reduce this
four-digit number to a single digit
example if a person was born on October
23rd 1972 10 23 and 1 97 to add the
month 10 to the day 23 plus the year
1972 arriving a total of two thousand
five so the years is 2013 then add the
digits it hold on I just see you like
you're ready to just type in anything
that I say we're gonna do it add the
digits in 2005 arriving at the Life Path
number seven so you're gonna be adding
two plus one plus three six yes
I'm six so you're six that's my number
six yeah we will you remember six I'm
gonna forget it yeah okay okay add nine
plus 1 5 plus 1 9 8 6 equals your 3 sum
of three in your cell yeah yeah I'm
better I'm more slowdown Aries I don't
think this is the competition okay
everybody gets a number somewhere higher
than others these are their stories
done okay it's not a competition
yeah I'm a six in here three yes okay
sorry that sounds like I'm winning but
go off okay okay
the master numbers 11 and 22 have been
incorporated within the corresponding
single-digit number reading see
additional okay if we were going to read
about that we'll read about that if you
choose to consider the master numbers
you can stop reducing the compound
numbers when you arrive at the master
numbers okay for example Bill Gates is
born ten twenty eighth nineteen fifty
five has a birth date that adds up to
nineteen ninety three nineteen ninety
three reduces to twenty two so he'd be a
good example of the twenty 2/4 or like
if your if your number comes out to
either four or two you could stop at
your master number which is 11 or 22
okay or some [ __ ] I don't understand
quite yet my bad I'm fully I'm I know
exactly what's going on all right how
about we read about your master number
first yes read about a six go are you
okay I'm ready okay I'm ready to learn
how bad I want you okay
so this is similar to reading birth
charts right it's gonna talk about my
character traits and stuff why are you
okay how good I am
don't we read your turn
no all right the Life Path 6 suggests
that you entered this plane you entered
a plane I'm already here with tools to
become the ultimate nurturer and beacon
for truth justice righteousness and dumb
assist study almost your domestic do I
have a window seat on the plane okay
your paternal or maternal as the case
may be instincts with a life six path
exceed all the six back no Julian a life
see your your paternal instincts are
exceed all others by a considerable
considerable margin so this basically
called you a hell with dad
you're basically a ultimate dad okay it
explains why you have so many fanny
packs
I love my fanny packs I have a good
collection and it is a growing
collection buy my fanny pack soon okay
whether in the home or in the workplace
you are the predominant caretaker and
family head I'd say that's true I would
agree while the six may assume
significant caretaker are significant
responsibilities in the community the
life revolves around the immediate home
and family for this is the most domestic
of numbers conservative principles and
conjunctions are deeply ingrained and
define your character hmm you are
idealistic and must feel useful to be
happy I'd say that as well why is that
specific to me just other people on
earth who don't need to be useful they
feel like they can just like do nothing
and they're happy I think there's plenty
of people that feel like that'd be
useful or be nothing I love to do
nothing it's like my favorite things so
that's like when you like invite me into
the kitchen while you're doing something
and like I pick up a spoon and start
stirring something or I start mixing
something like I have to be useful yeah
oh my god I was cooking that I don't
know why you just inserted yourself into
what I was I mean you know it's not
always useful you're just fulfilling
your need to feel news use well if I
feel like I'm being useful then I'm
useful right the main contribution you
make is that of advice service and
ever-present support you are a
humanitarian of the first order it is
your role to serve others and you start
in the home environment humanitarian
sounds sort of like like lakitu humans
like vegetarian eat vegetables like
humanitarian I'm a humanitarian you go
to a restaurant hey do any humanitarian
options no we don't serve people here
sorry side note sidebar trying to be
useful K you are very human and
realistic about life and you feel that
the most important thing in your life is
the home the family and the friends
this is the life path related to
leadership by example and assumption of
responsibility
thus it is your obligation to pick up
the burden and always be ready to help
if you are like the majority of with
Life Path 6 you are the only one who
will willingly carry far more than your
fair share of any load and you are
always there when needed
that's very true in doing so you take
ownership and often become an authority
over the situation in romance oh I'm
ready the six is loyal and devoted a
caretaker type you are apt to attract
partners who are somewhat weaker more
needy than yourself someone you can care
for and protect the main ingredient that
must prevail in their relationship is
complete harmony you don't function well
in stressful relationships that become
challenges for you to control it is the
same with friends you are loyal and
trustworthy but there is a tendency for
you to become dominating and controlling
it's likely you'll feel compelled to
function with strength and compassion
you are sympathetic a kind person
generous with personal and material
resources wisdom balance and
understanding are the cornerstones of
your life and these define your approach
to life in general your extraordinary
wisdom and the ability to understand the
problems of others is apt to commence
from an early age this allows you to
easily span the generational gap and
assume an important role in life early
on the number-6 life path actually
produces few negative examples but there
are some pitfalls peculiar to the path
you may have a tendency to become
overwhelmed by responsibilities and it's
slave to others especially members of
your own family or close friends
overwhelmed by responsibility that is so
far all of this is very true yeah it's
easy for you to fall into a pattern of
being too critical of others you also
have a tendency to become too hard on
yourself
the misuse of this life path produces
tendencies for you to engage in
exaggeration over expansiveness and
self-righteousness modesty and humility
may not flow easily imposing one's views
in an interfering or meddling way must
be an issue of concern the natural
burdens of this numbers are heavy and on
rare occasions responsibility is
advocated by a person with Life Path 6
this rejection of responsibility will
make you feel very guilty and uneasy and
will have very damaging effects upon
your relationships with others so yours
is like mostly positive I thought that
was pretty positive yeah
so you basically you're a domestic God
with multiple fanny packs and your
paternal instincts are like another and
I'm so useful I'm like there's nothing
that I do that's wasteful I just use I
use everything that we have in the in
the situation to optimize performance
and weights not what not is my motto and
if I agree I was gonna say as someone
that I like astrology I wouldn't say
that it's my end-all be-all I think it
makes her a much funnier joke than like
a practical resource but like Who am I
to say that it's not a real thing you
know what everyone's like it's [ __ ]
like how do you know it's [ __ ] yeah
as much as how much you don't know what
is or isn't whatever like I would say
that the Aries description is a little
more like if that's you in a nutshell
yeah mm-hmm it's funny this isn't wrong
no no it's not but it's funny like this
was me literally like years ago before I
knew what any of this was but this was
me is the person who like in in the
fashion of their character and their
astrology signs in that fashion fighting
or angry against people who believe in
this but doing it in that way which is
literally proving the point they're
trying to argue you know I like the part
where it was like I'm domestic I'm um I
feel that you are very dumbest I'm
domestic I feel like when it's
dinnertime pop is ready to cook sorry
that's sorry for saying Papa with his
domestic father so that I mean that's
just one part that's just your Life Path
number yeah you want to read mine yeah
read yours
you read my inter I'm scared where's
where does it start
I'm OH three or three raisins life not
three okay Life Path three indicates
that you entered this plane with a
strong sense of creative creativity and
the ability to use your phone to order
anything from a restaurant that may not
have delivery services with postman's
mostly this is the delivery app for
restaurants and businesses that don't
deliver but cannot deliver to you via
the power of an app on your phone and I
post me out in the world
getting exactly what you need whether
you need crushed Tomatoes from the
grocery store or pasta with crushed
Tomatoes used medicinal on you can get
either of those or you can just get Taco
Bell or you can just get Chipotle or you
can just get like five pounds of cheese
if you want it whatever you want
post mates will get it done for you
download the post mates app see what's
available in your area you will be
surprised at all the different options
you have every day if you don't feel
like leaving or you can't leave you're
stuck at home you're doing something
that you can't run away from but you're
hungry and you need something post mates
is there for you and they support the
podcast they support us mind you they
have incredible customer service anytime
I've had a problem with an order they
I've reached out and they've gotten
right back to me which is such a huge
thing when it comes to that because
mistakes happen to everybody but when
they're there to help you and be aware
of the fact that you are a paying
customer postmates scares you guys and
right now they care extra $100 worth of
delivery charges extra go to the post
mates app on your phone enter code Jenna
Doolin you get $100 towards your
delivery credit for the first seven days
of using the app check it out you will
really really not regret it it is
amazing it's streamlined easy app is
optimized
I might even use it later tonight Life
Path 3 ok Life Path 3 indicates you've
entered the Taco Bell restaurant no no
no more don't just read mine like it's
talked about like I read yours nice and
fair come on
first of all you already trolled me by
reading LifePath three indicates that
you entered this plane with a strong
sense of creativity with wonderful
communications you call me wonderful
like I can communicate so wonderfully
your communication Dwarfs everybody
else's I've ever met including my own
achievement for you most likely comes
through engaging your ingenious
expression a truly gifted three
possesses the most exceptional
innovative skills normally in the verbal
realm writing speaking acting or similar
endeavors here we are at apt if apt to
find the entertainers of the world
bright effervescent sparkling people
with very optimistic attitudes I see
that you're very optimistic the bright
side of this path stress is harmony
beauty and pleasures of sharing your
inventive talents with the world
capturing your ability in creative
self-expression is the highest level of
attainment for this life path life is
generally lived to the fullest often
without much worry about tomorrow that's
not true here I worry you're worried but
I live today you're not very good you're
not very good at handling money because
a general lack of concern about it ok
let me say I do have a general lack of
concern which is why I'm like not the
greatest business person cuz I don't
like do anything and everything for
money so yeah that's not wrong you spend
it when you have it and you don't when
you don't the three loves connecting
with people so true wait what the
connect three love's connecting with
people you love connecting people the
characteristics of a three hour warmth
and friendliness a good
conversationalist social and open all
you a good talker both from the
standpoint of being a delight to listen
to but even more importantly the one who
has the ability to listen to others good
that's very true your good listener
accordingly the life path reproduces
individuals who are always a welcome
addition to any social situation and
know how to make others feel at home
you're a good host
in a lot of ways they approach to life
tends to be exceedingly positive
disposition is almost surely sunny and
open-hearted a happy and often inspired
person you are constantly seeking and
needing the stimuli of similar people I
don't think you constantly need to be
stimulated by other people maybe in a
way of like connecting with people
online like you watch you watch people
right you're not like constantly you're
surrounded by people though I don't need
to be around people but I do seek like
those connections with people that are
fulfilling to me yeah for sure
like if I if I have a friendship with
someone that's not like if I'm not I
don't feel like on the same page as them
I don't feel the need to like you know I
think that's just part of being on
somebody feeds like a part of your soul
you always want them around yeah Brett
let me just couldn't never get enough of
breath yeah I agree there was a remote
side to your life three life paths as
well this comes as a surprise to the
native and those hermit he's trying to
make an escape and and to those who
think they are well-acquainted the three
is actually a very sensitive soul one
hurt you can easily retreat to a shell
of morose silence for extended periods
nonetheless the three eventually copes
copes with all the many setbacks that
incur in life and readily bounce back
from bounces back for more
it is usually easy for you to deal with
problems because you can freely admit
the existence of problems without
letting them get you down for too long
that's true you're a problem solver I
would say because of your own
sensitivity to hurt you have a caring
disposition and seem to be very
conscious of other people's feelings and
emotions in romance the three is a very
ardent and loyal lover Affairs that
don't go well can leave scars that
seemed to linger emotional experiences
of all sorts tend to deeply touch the
three and the drama may take some time
to play out regrettably the giving
disposition of the three often attracts
demanding partners as with most of
life's issues for the three is life path
balance and relationship balance in
relationships are is elusive yeah
your your big test with the three life
paths is controlling your highs and lows
you won't survive very well in any
routine environment or when you're
placed under a dominating management
slow thinking and overly contemplative
people tend to frustrate you and you
don't function too well with this type
whether you are working for with or
under them
your exuberant nature can take you far
especially if you are ever able to focus
your energies and talents for the few
living on the negative side of this life
path a three may be so delighted with
the joy of living that the life becomes
frivolous and superficial you may
scatter your abilities and express
little sense of purpose the three can be
an enigma for no apparent reason you may
become moody and tend to retreat
escapist tendencies are not uncommon
with the three life paths and you find
it very hard to settle into one place or
one position guard against being
critical of others impatient intolerant
or overly optimistic Wow a lot of that
really does sound like me
yeah yeah especially it's just like oh
[ __ ] you got a tendency to just like be
a recluse and someday you'll just decide
you've had it and disappear well
sometimes yeah I mean sometimes you feel
like that I know you do sometimes you
feel like you literally just don't want
to interact with anybody barely me I
know but that's also always been like my
life I'm like yeah Sunday I'm just gonna
buy a farm and move there yeah yeah but
the part where it's like you're a good
listener you're a good conversationalist
you every time someone compliments you
on that you know you're I feel like your
immediate responses are yeah went to
school for it right but that's not true
like that's the person you are you're a
good listener you like having
conversations with people ah Oh any time
we introduce a new person into your life
or our lives like say a friend of mine
comes over and we're drinking together
hanging out together or a new friend you
know and and we're talking you know the
talk usually goes on a long time because
they're able to vocalize things with you
because you're they're listening yeah
yeah that's that's that's a special
thing I think Thanks that's pretty cool
it is cool I wanna see some other stuff
so that's just your life path no
mm-hmm so now we got a I guess your like
whole name this is what's crazy to me
right so like the Life Path number makes
sense to me because I guess in theory
you can't have control over the month
the day and the year that you your horn
yeah well like your name is given like I
get the whole idea of like you know
sacred geometry and like everything is
math and you know whatever these things
exist in numbers but like your name was
given your mom could have just as easily
named you Bob as she did Julian so like
when you come up with a number that
correlates with your name does that how
can that mean something I don't know
maybe it ties all the way back to the
the number sign of my mom who named me
and what she was thinking when she came
up with that name I don't know okay
would you like to learn about numerology
keywords or would you like to learn
about the expression or destiny numbers
oh that's that expert you're the one
that thinks that that's gross and you're
doing it he's gonna give you highs okay
expression or destiny numbers is the one
that is your full name I guess your sole
urge or heart's desire number is based
on the vowels in your name which one you
want to do which one of those ooh well
I'm just let me read the rest of them to
your inner dreams number or personally
personality number is based on the
consonants in your name your birthday
number is the day of the month you were
born
Oh a mini reading for each day we could
do that really quick let's do that yeah
all right let me see so mine's the 15th
yours is the 17th all right with a
birthday on the 15th of any month you're
apt to have a really strong attachments
to home family and domestic scene mise
[ __ ] the one in five equalling six
provide the sort of energy that makes
you an excellent parent or teacher you
are very responsible and capable this is
attractive and attracting influence you
are like harmony in your environment and
strive to maintain it you tend to learn
by observation rather than study and
research you may like to cook but you
probably don't follow recipes that is a
lie
recipes that need to follow them exactly
eat but think about this right like a
15th of April is even more of an Aries
than I am know this I feel like you take
this one with a grain of salt this
number shows and artistic learnings and
would certainly support the talents that
may be otherwise in your makeup you're
very generous and giving person but
perhaps a bit stubborn in ways a bit
Beach okay 17th mm-hmm your birthday on
the 17th of the month suggest that you
are very fortunate financially because
this date is very good for business
interests and a solid business sense
although you're probably very honest and
ethical this birthday enables you to be
shrewd and successful in the world of
business and commercial enterprise you
have very excellent organization
organizational managerial and
administrative capabilities enabling you
to handle large projects and significant
amounts of money with relative ease
you are ambitious and highly
goal-oriented although you may be better
at starting projects than you are at
finishing them that's pretty [ __ ]
high and that's the tea a sensitivity in
your nature often were repressed below
the surface of awareness makes it hard
to give or receive affection again I
think you take the day one with a little
grain of salt because it's so general
but yeah I think starting things without
finishing them I know that's like a bad
thing about people and like that's
frowned upon but yeah I generally like I
don't have this thing inside me to wear
like you have it where you're like if I
start something I don't care what it is
what it turns out to be if it's good or
bad I'm going yeah you're a
completionist I'm not like that
I am a completionist it was just why I
spent like two years of my life playing
elder scrolls until I maxed out my level
what about relationships looking at a
relationship using numerology can be fun
and enlightening take a look
droolin yeah I'm gonna read yours and
you read mine well let's see if we're
compatible okay numbers that produce
easy compatibility or seem to be a
natural fit three six nine oh sure
compatible okay numbers that are usually
compatible and find it easy to get along
three and six
numbers that can go either way or maybe
neutral you know what's interesting is
that correlates to the year of birth not
just the sign mm-hmm right that's what's
interesting numbers that are often a bit
of a challenge and require much
compromise ours don't owe three and six
yeah
so we require compromise sometimes yeah
like down in the bottom I don't fully
understand this chart I'm just I think I
do you can let us know one that comes
not 100% sure all right let me find
three and six together because there's
one for like every single combination
ever mm-hmm alright three and six this
is a natural combination that works well
in most cases the three is full of
enthusiasm and ideas
that's me Beach and the six provides the
stability support and encouragement that
often makes this combination and idea
team in many ways idea team the idea
team Jenna punch herself in the face the
other night I did it was an accident she
was doing me like this it was a rogue
uppercut I was very excited that
snapchat filters were on Twitch anyways
the chemistry here is very strong and
durable the challenges of this
combination can come in the form of six
jealous feelings towards the oft
flirtatious three that's true I'm very
flirtatious I was voted biggest flirt in
high school and I had a boyfriend for
all four years but it's not like
flirting I'm just like listening to
someone people take that as flirting
yeah it's funny how if you just listen
to someone talk they think you're
flirting yeah usually it will be the six
who will have to learn to deal with an
inborn trait
what's an inborn trait what does that
mean inborn training born I don't know
what's in born
sounds like inbred mmm-hmm sure does
okay that's fun so according to
astrology virgos and Aries don't really
like well it's not like we're the ideal
sign for each other anymore ology but
that's not to say if you're a Virgo
dating an Aries your numerology will
agree it's because of our years too
because numerology factors in when you
were you're you were born in 86 I was
born in 92 that has something to do with
our numerology because if I was born in
86 what would my number be four plus one
plus seven so that's 12 plus oh wait do
you multiply yeah you multiply it let me
try this I want to try this really quick
just to see if I was born in the same
year as you four times 17 times 1 986
wait wait it's plus write or do you'd
multiply it plus 4 plus 1 7 plus 1 2007
so I'd be a 9 yeah interesting yeah all
right are you ready to do your name yeah
it's called the destiny number destiny
number I want to know the Destiny number
tell me - I'm getting a little invested
in this because this that our Life Path
number is your Life Path number but your
destiny number is something different it
has a different reading and then like
your hearts soul urge like I need to
know I want to know
tell me destiny number Queen so what
you're gonna have to do is you're gonna
have to write out a number for each of
the letters in your name okay yeah so do
you take your full name okay Julian Noah
so Lomita okay so give me the let me see
the key okay hold on let me just give
you a give me a might hold on all right
so Jay you're 1 I can it be easier if I
just looked at it I'll just tell you
okay wine 1 3 mm-hmm 3 mm-hmm 9
mm-hmm 5 5 so that's Julian who spaced 5
6 1 8 now we're moving onto your last
name one six three six four nine two one
right mm-hmm did I do it right cuz I
don't want to [ __ ] it up
how I supposed to know
is that enough letters for your name
yeah I'm just trying to organize it okay
so it says yeah this is correct what my
name is
one three three nine five five five six
one eight one six three six four nine
two one
okay well listen oh okay this this says
example of destiny number david michael
mclean david equals 22 over for michael
equals 33 over six McClain equals 28
which reduces to 10 over 1
I'm so confused so destiny number is 4
plus 6 plus 1 equals 11 and 11 the
master number did we do this wrong to my
destiny number is 11 over 22 I don't
understand okay we I didn't read enough
I'm so confused we see you just okay to
arrive at your destiny number take each
name separately and add up the letter
values yeah well I thought that's what I
was giving you the numbers yeah that's
fine are you good no nicknames okay
bubble ba tourneys so you add up each
individual name yeah I think yeah mm-hmm
29 31 32 okay I got him so you have
twenty six twenty and thirty two yeah
those are my three but then do you do do
you come up with eight two and five I
don't understand how do you get to a
single number okay yeah I think you do
four plus six plus yeah you add them
together yeah these are all added no you
add them all together you supposed to
get one number oh okay 46 plus 32 this
is an eight that's a two and that's a
five oh I see I see we got eight two and
five that's 15 and then your six right
oh yeah dude yes thanks again yeah so
your destiny number is also six yeah
yeah yeah that's crazy okay I got it I
got it
get me do yours now yeah okay okay let
me read you the numbers yeah
all right one five five five one five
mm-hmm nine three eight I'm thinking how
to spell it six three five mm-hmm next
one yep okay four six three yeah nine
five seven okay cool
all right let me add these up fifteen
sixteen seventeen one seven fourteen
seventeen plus it's fun twenty-five
thirty one thirty four thirty nine and
then 10 plus 12
don't get it wrong you don't get it
twelve is 34 okay so you're eight twelve
yeah eight plus three I don't know do
you reduce 12 2 plus hold on to save yes
yeah yeah yeah 12 plus 7 19 you're 19
now you're 1019
10 yeah it can't be 10 it only goes to 9
so see these are the three numbers 1739
34 right 1 plus 7 is 8 right 3 plus 9 is
12 3 plus 4 is 7 so 8 12 7 then you add
them all up right 8 plus I don't know if
you can do 12 like you might have to add
it again so that it's 3 I did it wrong I
don't know I don't know no I'm telling
you my math is wrong so I got a
different number now
what's what's the single digit number
it's a nine you're nine because eight
plus one plus two right that's 12 wait 8
plus 1 is 9 plus 2 is 11 plus 7 is 18 1
plus 8 is 9 8 plus 1 is 9 right no no no
no no but I don't know if you if you do
8 plus 1 plus 2 or you do 8 plus 12 no I
think you know I don't think you I don't
think you do a plus well because the way
I did it above is is I you know I didn't
add 22 I didn't add 8 to 20 I added 8 to
2 I'm pretty positive you're not I'm
pretty positive as did that right
because I did the exact same way I did
the one above okay that's okay
I trust me I did the exact same way so
your three numbers went from 8 17 to
39:34 all the way down to 9 I did it
right I did it right
so you're six exactly sorry 69 beat
alright well hopefully I'm reading the
correct destiny because we could have
done this wrong because it's not
completely clear yet I mean yeah here's
your destiny are you ready yeah the
number six destiny suggests the
direction of growth in your lifetime
will be toward a greater sense of
responsibility love and balance
development in life must make you more
helpful conscientious and capable of
rectifying and balancing any sort of
inharmonious situation you must be a
person very much inclined to give help
and comfort to those in need you have a
natural penchant for working with the
old the young the sick or the
underprivileged as the saying goes
charity begins at home and the home is
where you must be a special person the
qualities of six make the finest and
most concerned parent ooh so you would
dad again
and one who often deeply is involved in
domestic activities openness and honesty
is apparent in your approach to all
relationships particularly close family
relationships a happy home life is the
goal and of destiny six and if you live
up to the promises of this number you
will reap this reward most likely with
some degree of luxury and grace although
you may have considerable creative and
artistic talents at talents the chances
are that you'll devote your
to the occupation that shows concern for
the betterment of the home and the
community at large the destiny of six is
often in a career of medicine well for
her work education dealing in the arts
furniture decorating landscaping home
construction religious endeavors or
scientific fields Wow
spot on the arts is the closest I've
gotten with girl baseball God baseball
Oh God basil your soy crop your soy
market on to Tamar the miracle is jugar
real basil the positive side of number
six suggests that you are very loving
friendly and appreciative of others you
have a depth of understanding that
produces much sympathetic kindness and
generosity if there's an excess of the
number six in your makeup you may
exhibit some of the negative traits
associated with this number this can
include stubbornness self-righteousness
or dominance there may be a tendency for
you to be too exacting and demanding of
yourself in this regard you may at times
sacrifice yourself or your loved ones
for the welfare of others many with the
destiny of the number six worry too much
in other cases overzealous six has
difficulty distinguishing helping from
interfering that's fair I think most of
that is good that is the most Julian
sentence I've ever heard difficulty
distinguishing helping and interfering
other than that I don't really know if
we did this mask should that make much I
make my Twitter about I don't know I
don't know if we did this math correctly
doing your math I don't know no we did
we did it sounds nothing like you other
than just being a hella dad know it I
think it does well know when I read nine
if this is nothing like you then we
totally [ __ ] up but I think this whole
the number nine destiny suggests that
the direction of growth in your lifetime
will be in benevolent activities in
compassion and in worldly understanding
you are living up and growing towards
your destiny when you follow your
feelings Kermit watch the keyboard come
on
when you are follow your feelings and a
sense of compassion and allow yourself
to be sensitive to the needs of others
you must be willing to help others as
you were intended to be the big brother
or big sister type you must work well
with people for you have the potential
to inspire creative ability imagine
nation and artistic talent often latent
are the highest order are of the highest
order are present in this destiny career
fields in which you can excel are many
and include advisory roles medicine
legal fields artistic fields diplomacy
and religion I feel like these are kind
of weird examples of careers but
whatever friendships affection and love
are extremely important your personal
ambitions must be maintained in a very
positive perspective never losing sight
of an interest in people and preserving
a sympathetic tolerant broad-minded and
compassionate point of view all that is
very very aligned with you I think if
you are able to achieve the potential of
your natural natural destiny in this
life you are capable of much human
understanding and have a lot to give
others again you're a giver undeveloped
or ignored the negative side of the 9
destiny can be very selfish and
self-centered if you do not actively
involve yourself with work that benefits
others you may tend to express just the
opposite characteristics it is your role
to be very involved with other people in
their needs but it may be difficult for
you to achieve this role aloofness a
lack of involvement and a lack of
sensitivity marked the low road of this
destiny
I'm hello I'm hello sometimes I feel it
like in social situations when I'm being
aloof I just you're a human Italian
Greyhound I am though like remember at
twitchcon we were just like waiting for
the elevator and I just kept throwing
something at the ceiling like I feel
myself when I'm just like I don't know
why I'm doing what I'm doing yeah I
don't I just feel a little weird yeah
and it's not like you're easily
distracted because you're not distracted
by anything it's just like you just go
aloof sometimes I'm just so it's almost
like in a defense mechanism like when
things are weird you just you're aloof
now it's like it's like how things
camouflage into the grass and in the
jungle and avoid a predator instead of
like being involved in a weird situation
you just become aloof and then all of a
sudden you don't have to deal with you
you uh you socially disappear means I
think it is you know you have a lack of
like you're you just kind of you're out
of it you're
paying attention to any one thing in
particular you're just kind of it's like
yeah it's like when you meet Kermit and
he comes up and he smells you you just
sort of like walks away and you're like
I can't tell if he likes me or not
yeah he's aloof a loofah he wants my loo
he wants her loofah
he tries to steal it every day i weirdly
think we've gained a little bit more
than the birth charts with the
numerology that's kind of surprising I
didn't think it was gonna you like give
anything new not to be well that's just
like some of it there's a lot of it
so we can do more potentially yeah but
like I really so I really like like
sacred geometry and all the like you
know Fibonacci sequence of the spiral
whatever that golden ratio is I like
that stuff I think it's really cool that
it just like happens in nature it's just
like [ __ ] thing yeah and like it
makes sense that numbers would have an
effect on some part of your life yeah
don't know if adding the numbers in your
birthday month year is that but like I
have no reason not to be like sure yeah
just like astrology yeah and you okay
sure maybe it's [ __ ] but sure maybe
it's not for me it's not maybe there's
some things in there that are more
accurate maybe I like to have fun you
take it with a grain of truffle salt I
just think it's fun yeah and that
anybody can do it like astrology you
know yeah numerology we are numerologist
now no no no no no I want to our
numerology no not anyone numerologist
anyone can add up their numbers and read
what are you an expert no no no welcome
Julian to my my lair of numbers sorry
cough did you just say call yes Julian
why don't shake me I don't grab some
being a number come on baby so do you
still think your numbers better than
mine yeah no no I don't mine's bigger so
I win
[Music]
who's with class no that was fun well
thank you guys for listening to us do
whatever that was I enjoyed it those I
enjoyed I really did I'm gonna be on
that website for the rest of me I like
that I like the way we do it where you
read mine and I read yours yeah it's fun
yeah
in our numbers get along they do widget
cuz like you're in areas and imma forego
why do we get along I was reading
someone was tweeting back and forth like
two people were talking about our birth
charts and they had our birth charts
which we massacred on that podcast we
don't we don't understand what it means
yeah you [ __ ] this up you did it
wrongly I don't know what it means how
am I supposed to just be an expert in
astrology I don't [ __ ] understand I'm
trying my best
well maybe we'll have somebody like an
expert help us in the future but so I
was watching two girls tweet back and
forth at each other like oh I really
like Jenna's chart I wonder how she
dates an Aries or whatever and then
someone sends her your birth chart and
she responds back and says oh because
he's a quote like in Asterix soft Airy
not soft on the firm Aries I'm firm and
strong let me flopped fanny pack we're
in Papa well alright it's really funny I
was watching people tweet back and forth
about our birthday
this one right that's why thank you guys
for hanging out have a wonderful week
we'll see you next time on the jinjo
podcast be good
[Music]